this is drugs this is your brain on
drugs
any questions back in the 70s
well this is liberalism this is your
country on liberalism well kind of has
the same effect fries it all up I don't
think that the left though realizes what
sort of an impact
they're insane policies are having on
the real middle-class working Americans
people who don't want any special
recognition they just want to get up in
the morning go to work make a decent
living and get home maybe crack open a
beer all right well take for instance
Portland Maine it's pretty far from the
border so they shouldn't be impacted
right by the illegal immigration crisis
well wrong The Wall Street Journal is
reporting that the city is being overrun
by asylum seekers to the point where
they're taking up 90% of Portland's
family shelters and city assistance for
them is drying up in fact 75% of all
population growth they saw between 2011
and 2016
what's from foreign-born individuals
this is for anyone spent any time up in
Portland and it's cold up there tonight
that is wild okay former governor of
Maine Paul LePage warned about this
years ago and he was called every nasty
name Under the Sun as a result all the
usuals racist xenophobic blah blah blah
well he joins me now governor how does
this influx of asylum seekers now
there's some from Central America there
are also refugees from Africa it's a
different you know different status but
how does this affect everyday citizens
as I like to call them the maniacs in
port Lord well lawyer what it really
does it takes away from the disabled the
elderly people with intellectual
disabilities they're pushed aside
they're put on waiting lists and the
money goes to salim seekers and
undocumented citizens that come to
people that come to the state of maine
and that's been going on for years when
i was governor we had litigation again
the city of Portland for that exact
reason I when the economy started
getting better I removed all the
waitlist we there was 4200 people on
waitlist we budgeted for it totally
balanced budget paid for it the
Democrats came in took the money and put
the people back on a waitlist and
they're still there now on a waitlist
people who have lived their lives in
Maine and now without services in their
aging years or with their disabilities
and particularly the one that is the
most upsetting is intellectual
disabilities have gone by the wayside
mental health issues and so forth a lot
of people who after the Great Recession
2008 they they still haven't gotten a
leg up even with the improved economy
and Maine has always you know had some
struggles in that area obviously I want
to play something from you from just
this was back in a town hall you did in
2018 and the reaction from the crowd
Swach 2016 sorry shame on you they were
screaming
well I recall I recall I think to speak
or the house is there that evening yeah
well what are they what are they saying
now I mean look at this I mean we have a
situation according to the statistics
today in Portland 65 to 70% of thousand
people now receiving general assistance
are non-citizens everyone here that 65
to 70% of the people sinking sea
receiving government assistance are
non-citizens another the city budgets of
about $200,000 annually to fill in gaps
for asylum seekers who don't qualify for
general general assistance such as those
who haven't yet filed an application so
you haven't filed in they're reaching
out to give you money in Portland this
is the Democrat Party though this
a state that is now with democrat
control democrat right is a legislate
state legislature
that's correct still run by democrats is
the governor and that and the incumbent
governor invited them has said it when
she in her when she's a governor-elect
she said I will invite asylum seekers to
come to Maine and I will give them
services and well if you invite they
will come when I when I think of all
these other cities that are considering
more generous policies toward both
asylum seekers refugees are different
again a different story what do you say
to them given Maine's own experience I
would say that if you have the resources
and you feel compassionate for these
folks go ahead and do it but if you're
going to be taking resources very very
impaired resources for your citizens
then you are making a big mistake
well again ninety percent of the people
living in Portland City run Family
Shelter an overflow shelter are people
who are asylum seekers overwhelmingly I
guess it's still from Africa correct
that is correct from Africa and and you
know one thing that Africa I don't get
the Somalis all went to Minnesota and
then they went to Maine the two climates
final I don't get that at all I don't
get how exactly the place where
everybody go oh well what it what is
that I I don't know but I will say this
the one thing that nobody's talking
about right now they're talking about
the resources being eaten up by by
temporary housing I'll tell you when
they get into housing you should see the
disgraceful housing that these people
are being put into in the city of
Portland I visited this housing it was
now housing that I was brought up in
which I gives me nightmares my entire
life it's terrible well governor the
you're seeing a total transformation of
New England cities and
Lawrence Massachusetts another one this
is happening all across New England but
Portland brought it on itself and people
are going to left to pick up the pieces
governor thank you so much